Wyoming has always been a state
that emphasizes rugged individualism.
We're pretty libertarian, always have been.
The Golden Hills of Wyoming,
an ever spinning wheel of fortune.
The coordinates mad world, adventurous, pioneers,
the renegade horse.
However, throughout Wyoming's history,
commodities, not rugged individualism
has powered its economy.
The commodity that we got established on was cattle
and the commodity that came into our future
fairly shortly thereafter was oil, and then came coal.
We're struggling right now to transition with that history
because we rely heavily on coal, oil, and gas
for most of our state's revenue.
There has been a long-term discussion
about diversifying our economy.
We've recognized that depletable resources we banked on,
coal and oil and gas are eventually gonna be depleted.
Today, Wyoming is looking to embrace a new commodity.
We need to find alternative industries and viable sectors.
Both blockchain and cryptocurrency represent values
that Wyoming can get online with.
As the world of blockchain and crypto
goes more and more mainstream,
the race for the state to be crown
in the most crypto-friendly is on.
When you think of crypto-friendly cities,
you have to start with Miami, Florida.
The Miami mayor, Francis Suarez.
I want us to differentiate ourselves as the crypto capital
of the United States or of the world.
New York City mayor, Eric Adams.
New York city is gonna be the center
of the cryptocurrency industry.
But that race is led by the Cowboy State.
It's about philosophy on this one.
And it's the philosophy of that rugged individualism,
the independence, and the ability to really get things done
for yourself and control your own destiny.
You get that from a blockchain,
and you don't get that without it.
My name is Caitlin Long,
I'm co-founder Avanti Financial Group,
which is a bank chartered to serve
the digital asset industry in Wyoming
that will be operating in 2022.
Caitlin Long was born in Wyoming,
but spent the majority of her career
working for Morgan Stanley in New York.
However, she's always kept one foot back home in Cheyenne.
Wyoming has a really interesting history of leading.
Wyoming gave women the right to vote 50 years
before the rest of the United States.
When Wyoming invented the limited liability company,
new form of business entity in 1977,
it took about a decade for the rest of the United States
to follow Wyoming.
Here Wyoming is leading yet again in digital asset laws,
we already are seeing other states follow.
I think it won't even take a decade
for the critical laws of Wyoming to be enacted
by the other states in the United States.
Because of champions like Caitlin Long,
Wyoming is leading the charge
when it comes to integrating blockchain and crypto
to U.S. law.
When I got into Bitcoin,
got some early coins, decided when it started running up
in the previous bull market in 2017
to donate some appreciated Bitcoin
to the University of Wyoming Foundation
to fund scholarships for female engineers.
And I thought,
well, I'll just quietly use some of my Bitcoin gains
to help solve that problem.
And the University of Wyoming
just sort of shrugged their shoulders
and probably said something
along the lines of "what's bitcoin".
The University of Wyoming could not accept her donation
because the state's money transfer laws
restrict certain kinds of assets.
I said at the time,
"We've gotta fix this
"because this Bitcoin thing is gonna be big
"and you don't wanna miss it."
We though, well, what are we doing that for?
That's ridiculous.
So in 2016, we started to look at
this Money Transmitter Act revision.
What started as an attempt to give back to her home state
ended with her leading the charge
on Wyoming's cryptocurrency and blockchain regulations.
We really started to realize that
there was an open landscape for developing policy
around blockchain and digital assets.
We got together at that point
and we kinda formed this little collaborative team
of enthusiasts and policymakers
that started planning for what a future could look like
with digital assets.
There were 90 people involved at the legislature
and about 30 people who endorsed this
outside of the legislature in the very beginning.
Since that time,
we put together the blockchain task force,
and now we formalized it into a permanent select committee.
After fixing the money transmitter statute,
the task force took on a whole host of other laws
concerning blockchain and crypto.
There've been 24 laws
passed in four different legislative sessions,
but I'd say the most important ones
are that Wyoming clarified the legal status
of digital assets.
We realized there was an open question
about what is a digital asset,
what is a cryptocurrency when it comes to property rights
and statutes?
If a court is looking at this asset,
what are they gonna do with it?
We defined it as property.
And that's the basis upon which financial services
can be built
and just basically making the law compatible
with the way the technology was actually working,
very foundational.
The next steps,
to fundamentally change the banking system in Wyoming
and possibly the country.
We have something called a dual banking system
in the United States
where some banks are chartered federally
and some banks are chartered by the states.
But if an organization dealt with crypto,
they were not allowed to use the U.S. banking system.
If you had crypto, if you had blockchain,
if you had any word associated with it in your name
or your business model or your business plan,
you wouldn't get banked.
And if you can't get banked, you can't have a business.
So we created a whole new type of state chartered bank
called a Special Purpose Depository Institution,
the SPDI bank.
It operates the core payment systems for the U.S. dollars,
specifically ACH and Fedwire.
And right now,
there are no crypto companies that have direct access
to that.
It's kept separate.
So banks can access that,
but they can't provide services for crypto.
It's a way to plug the digital asset industry
into the traditional financial services industry
in a safe and sound manner.
Importantly,
this would also give those crypto banks
if they were to get this SPDI access
to the feds payment system.
And that's really important
because that would really cut down on the cost and the time
that it takes for these transactions to go through.
If you go back to thinking about when you were kids
and you were exchanging baseball cards with your friend,
what did you do?
You both held onto both baseball cards
and you both let go at the same time.
And then you had simultaneous settlement
of that trade of the baseball card.
Nobody owed a baseball card to anybody
because the transaction happens simultaneously.
The adults screwed that up
and we should learn from the kids
because the kids had it right.
There's no reason why you should ever have an IOU
for the baseball card.
for a dollar payment.
We have the technology
to be able to do simultaneous settlement of a U.S. dollar
against other types of assets,
namely digital assets and others,
but we don't have the capability to do that
because of the regulatory regime.
And when I signed it,
I was very excited because no one else had really done that.
Everybody else was trying to figure out
how to shoe-horn digital asset custody
into an existing trust structure
or into some sort of existing banking structure.
Regrettably,
we see at the national level,
that there's a tremendous amount of resistance.
Crypto markets aren't actually an alternative
to our banking system.
They're a mirror of the same broken system
with even less accountability and no rules at all.
If you're buying stock for speculation,
you'd be protected by rules against things like pump
and dump,
but not when you're buying Bitcoin for speculation.
There are four chartered Wyoming SPDIs
and none of us have been approved by the federal reserve
yet.
One of cryptocurrency's biggest hurdles
really is that it is so new.
The fact that it is such a turbulent asset
can kind of spook some of traditional Wall Street
and professional money managers.
I do think they are risky. They're not backed by anything.
The reason they see resistance
is because we're creating a banking institution
that doesn't require FDIC insurance.
The reason it doesn't require FDIC insurance
is because it's not able to be at risk.
It's a 100% reserve,
a hundred percent depository institution.
that's incapable of lending out those funds.
I've been back to Washington two or three times,
I've been told that we're getting very close.
I think that governors and bank presidents understand
how important it is that the United States,
not just Wyoming,
but the United States actually jump ahead on this
because we are losing ground to China.
If we don't get in the game soon,
we are gonna be playing catch up.
Wyoming's Crypto Industry has some allies in Washington,
it's most famous, may be one of the state's own senators.
I encourage people to buy and hold.
I encourage them to save Bitcoin for their retirement,
for their future.
It's not the Wyoming way to sit around and
wait for change.
We wanna be innovative and we're gonna push back
as hard as we can against the feds.
It's not just cryptocurrencies.
Wyoming has taken the first step
towards recognizing companies, organizations,
and even cities run entirely on the blockchain.
July 1st, Wyoming became the first state
to formally legally recognize
decentralized autonomous organizations, or DAOs,
in our statutes.
And we created the DAO LLC.
It's a fancy way of saying you can establish a company
using blockchain and put it under an LLC moniker.
Wyoming really has been a leader in business activity
for decades.
LLCs were first established in Wyoming law.
And this is just an extension of that LLC.
We're kind of going back to the original roots
of how do you let people self-organize
and give them the ability to do a couple of things?
The idea of a DAO
is the idea that we're going to have some portion
of our company's responsibilities
delegated to algorithms, programming, code,
where code is going to run the company
as opposed to your manager
or members that show up every day to the office.
We're just gonna turn it over to code.
One of the biggest DAOs out there
that people know the most about
is a group that's known as Constitution DAO.
They crowdsourced a bunch of funding
to try to buy the U.S. Constitution at Sotheby's.
They actually raised over 40 million in less than two weeks.
We would really love to display that constitution
at the University of Wyoming.
And so, even the governor of Wyoming got involved
to try to basically market to the 15,000 people,
each of whom had a vote on where the constitution,
if the Constitution DAO had won,
where was that constitution going to be displayed?
Begin the auction -- lot 1787,
the Constitution of the United States of America.
The United States constitution at $41 million.
Sold 41...
They of course, lost to Citadel chief executive officer,
Ken Griffin.
But it really was sort of the proof of concept
for a lot of people when it came to DAOs.
We've already had over 150 DAOs filed
in the State of Wyoming.
The Billionaire Zombies Club is an NFT art collective
which is transitioning to DAO leadership.
Elisia is a career-based DAO project
that finances real estate with crypto.
You have crypto tokens like ELO coin space dogs,
and even a collective that plays blockchain based games
together.
There are companies from all over the world
that are now looking at Wyoming
as a place where they want to innovate
and create new products or technologies or businesses
that are formed through a DAO LLC.
And within Wyoming's own borders
is one of the most ambitious DAOs yet.
City DAO's citizens took advantage of Wyoming's new laws
by collectively purchasing 40 acres
near the Montana Wyoming border,
about six hours from Cheyenne.
Basic citizenship with voting rights is about $3,000.
And each subplot of land goes for $300.
City Hall is located on a discord where members share memes,
lofty goals and details of a recent hack.
Discord hack.
If you do any kind of business in this country,
there's a pretty good chance
that you're gonna see that business registered in Delaware.
Why? Because that's where you do it.
And our point was,
Wyoming can be that venue for blockchain enterprise,
for crypto.
We're seeing businesses from around the country
locate mining operations.
And in fact,
we just had one that moved its headquarters to Wyoming.
One of those businesses is Elite Mining.
Elite Mining is a green mining company that mines Bitcoin
and other algorithms on the blockchain.
Thank you, everyone, for coming.
I cannot begin to tell you
how humbling a moment this is for me.
Elite Mining is one of the first companies
that has actually shifted operations into Cheyenne.
Our company itself uses payroll through blockchain.
All of our employees, team members, contractors,
we pay them all through cryptocurrency.
The whole city as a whole has welcomed us with open arms,
roll out the red carpet for us, and essentially said,
"We wanna work with you."
I fit right in because I'm from a small town personally.
And this is more of a small town that's growing
into what I would call the cryptocurrency version
of Silicon Valley.
We wanna make sure that people understand,
especially in Wyoming,
but as United States as a whole, that this trend is coming.
It's not going to stop.
When we get to the point
where we've completely implemented
this blockchain technology,
when we have digital identities
that allow us to engage authoritatively with our banks
and with our government,
we can have privacy rights that we want,
not that are either allowed to us or forced upon us.
We want that independence. We want that freedom.
We want that individuality.
And that's a common theme that brings together
honestly, a bipartisan support for this in Wyoming.